each square in the grid is a unit square
with an area of one square centimeter
so each of these squares is one square
centimeter
this is one square centimeter and this
is one square centimeter and so on and
now we're asked what is the area of the
figure
by figure i'm sure they mean this bluish
purplish quadrilateral and we want to
know its area
an area is talking about how much space
the shape
covers
how much space does this quadrilateral
cover how many square centimeters
does the quadrilateral cover
to figure it out we could start by
counting here's one here's one square
centimeter the quadrilateral covers and
i can keep counting like that all of the
square centimeters that i can see here's
two three
another rows got some here
four
five
six
down here here's seven
eight
nine
so there's nine full
square centimeters
nine square centimeters but that's not
the entire area that's not everything it
covers
it also covers these small parts these
triangle
shaped little spaces of area
and so we need to count those two
let's look over here let's look if we
drew one of these triangles
into a unit square
and then we drew another one
on the other part half of this unit
square we would see that combined they
make one full unit square
so we can do that we can take this
triangle up here which is half of a unit
square
and combine it with this half of a unit
square
so if we combine these two together
that's one more unit square so now we
have nine full unit squares plus one
more
but there's still more of them so we can
keep combining
this half unit square
combined with the other one on the
bottom
makes a second
unit square
and finally there's two more halves
here one
two
which combine to make another whole so
we have nine full unit squares
plus
plus
three more unit squares that we made by
combining we made one by combining these
two a second unit square with these two
and a third unit square here so we have
nine full unit squares and then three
more unit squares we put together
which is a total
of 12
square units or 12
square in this case our unit is
centimeters 12 square
centimeters
our figure our quadrilateral covers 12
square centimeters so it has an area
of 12 square centimeters